Five you get less enthusiastic with after it's been a few times.
He'll like,
you're not really.
We're live.
All right.
What's up man?
How are you guys doing this?
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Sorry for the false starts.
We've been having issues with our equipment.
Good to see though,
man.
What's up?
Good to be here and talk.
Hunter Thompson.
My pleasure.
Um,
so your book free kingdom,
you know,
we live in interesting times right now.
It's kind of a kind of a shit show at every campus in a moment.
About a fist from your face.
Pull that sucker.
There you go.
My hands.
Should I put them on you?
Do whatever you want with your hands.
Shoot with this one.
What is all this a,
you got a lot of writing.
Well,
when I wrote the book,
I wanted to make sure my sentence never sounded like Thompson sentences,
right?
So I didn't write out a lot of his sentences.
But this morning before coming on,
I went and got some of my favorite quotes.
I'm just,
I'm out longhand to get a sense of what is a,
what his perspective was when rhythm.
Once again,
didn't he do that with the Great Gatsby?
He like a few times by hand.
He like typed it out.
Yeah.
I love that idea that he was trying to find like the rhythm of the words.
That's such a fascinating notion because comedians do that in the early days of
comedy,
like a lot of guys,
um,
in like before they ever start getting on stage themselves,
they'll imitate their favorite comedians.
Bits.
Like they'll do a Richard Pryor bit and they'll do it to their friends and
they'll get,
get a sense of the rhythm and the timing and get those laughs from doing a
Richard Pryor bit to their friends and then they get that bug.
It's like part of what infects them.
I mean,
that's the hardest thing to steal.
We're not plagiarizing,
but we're trying to understand what decisions they made.
Beautiful work.
Yeah.
I'm sure he wasn't plagiarizing,
but it's,
it's so unfortunate when,
when someone does,
yes.
You know,
when,
when you have someone,
whether it's a hunter or Richard Pryor or anyone who's just got a truly
exceptional and unique mind or someone who doesn't like our president and
decided when he ran in 2016 to plagiarize Richard Nixon's 1968 convention
speeches directly.
Really?
Yeah.
That was the headlight and the fucking times it said Nixon's inspiration.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
Trump's inspiration.
Nixon is the one.
So the light's about crime and I'm like barbarians at the gate,
crime,
law and order.
Those were all from Nixon's Shitty but successful.
1968 a Miami convention speech.
And Thompson Thompson knew how effective that that was.
Yeah.
I wonder if he did that on purpose because he was so good in one thing that
Trump is so good.
He's so good at getting the media to talk about him.
And like,
one of the best ways to get the media to talk about him was give them something
to be angry about that no one else is going to give a fuck about.
He was like,
oh,
well Narnia plagiarize,
but I plagiarize as much better from Nixon.
Right.
So it,
I loved it.
And Melania took some lines from Michelle Obama's speech,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
if you plagiarize Nixon,
that's okay.
All right.
So freaking done.
The book about Hunters Thompson,
I mean,
it's really about taking the fucking emotion of living in this present,
looking back at Thompson's and then trying to write it like a novel to dramatize
all of the experiences he went through that are today so applicable to us and
just show his perspective that's so applicable to us today.
What do you got in here,
Jamie,
from New York Times
or the inspiration and Nixon?
I was like,
are you,
you're running on Nixon,
that's what you're running on here.
Some parallels,
you know,
I mean,
do you remember when,
um,
when hunter got together with a Bill Murray and bill's brother and they did that
thing where they were trying to get people to a,
Nixon got a bad deal.
We've got to bring them back and people are going along with,
oh yeah,
that's a good,
yeah.
Yeah.
You mean for you?
I remember that.
Yeah.
Like that.
There's a lot of parallels with Trump in that regard.
I mean,
one of my favorite quotes by Thompson is like,
um,
you know,
Richard Nixon is with this Barbie doll family and his Barbie doll wife is like
America's answer to um,
you know,
it's America's doctor Jekyll and Mr. Hyde and like,
he is the Werewolf.
He speaks to the Werewolf in us and Nixon chose to hide that Werewolf his whole
career until it finally came out cause he was insane with power.
Trump ran on the werewolf.
He's like,
no,
I'm not gonna hide it.
That's who I am.
That's what I'm going to use to try to get elected.
And like George Wallace did,
like other politicians did.
It had resonance and it happened with Trump because of our media environment,
because of the place we live in now to amplify them all the way to the most
powerful position in the world,
which is insane.
It would be really fascinating to see if hunter was alive and in his prime.
Now how he was,
I think his take on it were very similar to Matt Tie EBS,
you know like Mad Eeb is in my opinion,
our more reasonable,
more put together version of Hunter Thompson because he's more stained
discipline,
long career version of the pathologies like rational and he's there all the
time.
Like the,
I'm sure you've heard the recently uncovered recording of hunter calling in to
some company that installed a DVD player and he's fucking screaming and yell at,
it's like 15 minutes and then he like gets lost.
I think that's what the fuck and the DVD player doesn't work.
Y'All got y'all my fucking cards.
I mean that was the 90 days are not the best.
You know,
I think what Toby does is what Thompson did very well on a Thompson was really
good at looking at Nixon and saying,
how are you manipulating the way we see you?
You get a version of you out and Toby looks at the way the media gets played.
He looks at the way that an administration manipulates the media and he
dramatizes that while everybody else just gives us the information the
administration is giving us.
And that goes back to Thompson with Nixon.
Thomson had space when he worked for rolling stone and he could write about how
Nixon made everybody watched his speeches,
the press on a closed circuit television and they made the press just like Trump
off in the corner when the plane arrived,
you know,
being berated by everybody.
It's very similar to what is going on now.
And again,
we see people getting hot takes are we see people doing op eds.
We don't see people dramatize it.
How manipulative these corrupt administrations are.
And were,
and Thompson did that beautifully.
Um,
Toby,
does that be a play?
Was a Nixon berated by the press?
Is that why he chose to have was,
I mean he was a crook,
so he doesn't want the press to investigate them.
Like he,
you know,
he was a crick with San Clemente,
like his loans with Bibi rebozo and all of that.
He was a quick,
the way you use the IRS to investigate his,
and if he was a Kirk when he tried to break into the Brookings Institution to
destroy and fom evidence,
like he didn't want the press around him because he'd committed very serious
crimes.
That I think that's similar to what we see now.
I mean,
as people sit on the show,
no,
no president wants the a journalist,
you know,
digging into their lives specifically because you don't want chubbiness with
journalists.
But I think Trump and Nixon both knew they had so much to hide that to actually
have a journalist like Hunter Thompson who was a good investigative journalist
to have my baby around,
that's dangerous for them.
They'll go to jail,
which Nixon should've have Trump perhaps should,
while who knows what's going to happen.
How did you,
uh,
how'd you get involved with a writing this book?
Well,
I mean I've always loved on her as Thompson in how did you get exposed to them?
You know,
in,
uh,
I was 17 years old in a Catholic high school at Bellarmine college preparatory
up in San Jose and we had a counterculture,
a writing class.
And so I read some of it in there and then a friend had an audio book,
the fear loathing.
And so I just remember the first time hearing that old audio book of fear and
loathing of where somewhere around Barstow on the edge of the desert.
And then in my twenties I really got into strange rumblings and Ozzie lawn,
which is about a conspiracy within the Los Angeles Police Department regarding
the death of Ruben Salazar.
I'm a prominent journalist and I read that,
I'm like,
oh my God,
dude,
this isn't somebody that's just dancing on stage or like performing a road
narrative.
This is an investigative journalist who's going to the most powerful people
exposing things they don't want us to see and in a sense risking his life to do
so because he says in strange room and leaves in Oslo Lawn,
which is in rolling stone in 1970 he says that they're willing to kill Ruben
Salazar who was the most prominent journalist in Los Angeles.
You could argue at the time what the fuck is to stop them from killing me.
Hunter Thompson for asking these questions.
Well,
I think that's what a lot of people are saying today with Jamil Shogi.
You know,
Jamal could shogi his death has got a lot of journalists really freaking out.
Like what?
You know,
what am I doing if I'm criticizing world leaders,
talking about international politics,
if this could happen to me,
political violence is effective because it's used to silence you either
opposition or journalists.
And so for me,
writing this book and I tried to dramatize it like a novel,
it's quick.
It's like only 200 2,210 pages and then it's like a hundred pages of notes.
So I like cited every sight,
smell or sound so that somebody that knows Thompson really well,
it can be like,
where the fuck did you get this information right and somebody else can,
if they have questions,
just go back and look.
But long story short for me,
the crux of the book was in Chicago in 1968 where a hundred Thompson at a press
pass,
he went to the Democratic National Convention on Wednesday night.
Mayor Daley gave this order to clear the intersection of Balbo in Michigan
because there was a protest going on.
Five 10,000 people.
Thompson was standing next to the Haymarket in which was on the ground floor
level.
It was a plate glass window he was standing with from the Democratic national
convention standing with their wives and the cops charged.
They did like a double pinch of formation like Hannibal and like um,
[inaudible] like fucking 100 BC and they split the protesters and half beat.
Everybody hit Thompson over the head.
He got his motorcycle helmet on just in time so he's not concussed.
He can see everything that's going on and the entire plate glass window behind
him shatters.
Everybody falls in,
cops jump in,
are beating everybody and he's looking around and he's sure that snipers on the
roof are gonna open fire at any moment.
So he runs to the Blackstone where he staying across the way shows his room key.
It gets beat up by the cops as you're trying to get any,
he goes,
I live here,
goddammit,
I'm paying $100 a day,
let me get my fucking room.
And he barely gets it and he just sits on his bed afterwards and he says they
knew I was pressed.
They saw my press pass,
the hit me because I was pressed.
And if that's where we're at right now with journalists,
you know,
political opponents and journalists are being clubbed to keep silent and to not
respond.
Then this is not the democracy.
We know.
Yeah.
His ex wife talked about that as being like one of the only moments where she
saw him cry for two weeks,
tops cried afterwards for two weeks.
He couldn't stop.
It was crazy.
It was a,
it was a crazy time,
right?
I mean,
that the time is very similar in a lot of ways to what's going on today.
It's just today there's just so much more information and so much more.
People have so much more of an ability to communicate.
Yeah.
And I think it's almost easier to coordinate violence.
I was just talking to the head of the proud boys.
You know,
Gavin McInnes is a group,
um,
Enrique Tario and he's like,
you know,
he's an advocate.
He's saying he's using the language of the left.
He's like,
I'm a victim.
I can't buy groceries.
They'd taken my big accounts,
my plant forms.
But when he talks about violence,
he's like,
who the fuck are you?
Antifa like I'm,
you know,
you're 120 pounds in wet.
Like we have civil war you're going to lose.
And I was sitting next to him during the podcast and basically what I said was,
if we have a civil war,
you're going to be hit by a sniper fire from the fucking roof.
You're not going to be in a fist fight with antifa across the way.
And I think there's this idea on the right that we can push towards violence and
we can get very close to it with our rhetoric or with our actions,
but that it won't spread.
Like the conflagration won't keep going.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's how I slid to the right.
I mean not with Antifa and the left too,
and that's why I love Thompson was as hard on the left as he was on the right
when he wrote and it was so important for his intelligence as a writer.
But I think just even the left and the right in general for a lot of these
people is just an identity and a gang that they belong to.
And I don't think they really understand violence.
You know,
you want to talk about violence,
talked to a military guy.
You don't talk to someone who really understands what violence actually is and
they don't have this empty rhetoric like these fools do.
Exactly as a lot of these people that are calling for violence like,
no,
you should be calling for comradery and you should be calling for communication.
We should be calling for some way.
We could all work this out where the civilians,
the s,
the civilization that we live in,
that we all,
we all can get along together and most people
don't want to impede you from living your life and doing what you want to do.
Most people,
the vast majority a hundred times of believed in working within the system.
He know he believed like it might be a fucked up system,
but you can still run for sheriff in Aspen and he believe in,
once you resort to violence,
that means the conversation has stopped and it disfigures you.
So he cried for two weeks.
That was the most surprising thing for me researching this book and writing it
was to see how much the violence affected him that he experienced at Chicago.
You can speak to someone who's done and then they fighting has been punched in
the face as hard as somebody can punch you.
Most Americans haven't had that and that changes your ability to articulate
something back in that moment.
It means you,
if that's political,
if it's a police officer or a political opponent that uses violence instead of
an argument to respond to you.
We've,
we've left the realm that we recognize and we're not going to be able to
communicate even in the limited way that we're communicating right now at
Thompson knew that.
So that's why after Chicago,
I love that he went back to aspen and he's like,
I'm going around fucking sheriff.
I'm going to do a mayoral campaign and Aspen.
And that was brilliant because it was his way to control his environment,
knowing that Mayor Daley's not listening to his nonviolent protest.
Richard Nixon is not listening to his nonviolent protest.
Thompson needed to find another avenue to try to work within the American system
to make things happen.
And a great contrast is his good friend on Oscar Zeta Acosta.
There's a wonderful PBS documentary at rise and fall of the Brown buffalo by,
I'm Philip Rodriguez,
a great director.
And it's a cost his life,
uh,
to Dr. Gonzales based on shore and fellow the,
you know,
Thompson had more advantages than Acosta and Acosta was being perceived by the
LAPD was eventually set up by them and for him working within the system he ran
for sheriff wasn't an option.
The Cobb set him up for a high speed bust,
you know,
like the cops had,
the cops had undercover agents from something called the special operations for
conspiracy,
which is a fucking department in the LAPD at the time.
And they were trying to use those provocateurs to incite violence against the
plainclothes please.
So that or the normal clothes police so that lethal violence could be used to
silence us civil rights movement in the Brown bread.
So they used agent provocateurs to make it look like they're a part of the
protest.
Yeah,
there was an age old tactic,
right.
That's how you destroy the civil rights movement.
Because the most effective weapon in silencing civil rights is lethal force.
And you can do that in another country as the u s has done.
But the West can't use tactics like my lie,
like Thompson writes about this in the US,
unless you have a provocative reason,
unless somebody that's undercover attacks a cop.
And so the cops then like would happen on August 29th,
1978 during the moratorium riots can just flood east la whoever they want and
they can,
the blue ribbons haulers art's head off with a tear gas gun.
Uh,
yeah,
those are darker days when you couldn't communicate as well.
And then I think that's one of the reasons why a hundred decided to run for
sheriff in Aspen is that he felt like he could control that area.
Like it would have a direct impact on his life.
The local politics have a real impact in your day to day existence,
whereas what's going on in Washington for the most parts on affecting you if
you're living in Woody Creek?
I mean there were people that hadn't Nixon's point of view in Aspen who are
like,
let's develop this valley beyond what it can hold in terms of its environment.
Let's,
um,
in prison hippies because they are going to take away from our tourists on,
you know,
economy,
let's,
um,
you know,
not have or not adhere to normal like civil rights laws.
And so Thompson,
you know,
in a participatory democracy,
almost a Jeffersonian democracy,
um,
way ran for sheriff by emphasizing personal agency and most of all trying to get
up the youth vote.
Like people who had left the political system.
But we're living in Aspen,
a lot of people who like hippies who had fled the cities in the late 1960s and
we're living,
you know,
in,
in the West.
And he got them involved and they should have won the mayor mayoral campaign
with a Joe Edwards that Thompson was the director of that and they lost by like
six votes.
Then when he ran for sheriff,
it cut really bad.
And he talks about this in fairly early on the campaign trail later is that a
few nights before both parties,
the Democrats and the Republicans freaked out.
And so the Democrats said,
all right,
we'll kind of throw our weight behind you,
the Republican sheriff,
and then you Republicans will throw your weight for county manager behind our
candidate.
And so Thompson and Bluesy by like two or 300 votes.
And so in fear and loathing in Las Vegas on the campaign trail in 1972,
he's um,
at the Nixon campaign,
um,
Nixon's giving his acceptance speech at the convention.
Thompson's with the Nixon youth who are about to do a demonstration.
And he says like,
you know,
I'm not a journalist,
you can't kick me out.
Like I'm a political observer.
He's like,
have you ever run for office?
And then Nixon guy is like,
no,
have you and Thompson's like sheriff and I would have won.
But the liberal stuck it to me.
I love how he shaved his head.
It was long haired opponent.
I mean that was a great,
that debate.
So in the book I recreate that debate a lot.
Like,
cause there's transcripts of it that the beat is brilliant.
It is Thompson.
It's amazing.
The guy's like,
I've only used my gun once in 10 years,
but I like to have it [inaudible].
It's like,
well,
if you've used it once in 10 years,
maybe you don't need it.
We could try not having it.
You know,
in his gun rights,
um,
views were very complex and changed after Bobby Kennedy's death.
But he was so intelligent on stage with the sheriff who's like,
I just want this job.
Had like Gulping,
like,
you know,
it couldn't,
this was this cerated by Thompson.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a,
it's a really interesting,
the,
the documentary that follows the campaign and when you get to see him,
you know,
heartfelt phone when he loses and you got a sense of what,
that there was real hope back then like that.
If these guys could do that.
And what's interesting now is,
um,
you know,
back in the 70s they really did have a free community and Aspen.
That shit,
it's gone now.
I don't know what happened in EHRs have replaced the millionaire.
I was told when I went out to do research place,
man,
you go to Aspen,
he seen it.
He was like $20 million houses and people like,
it's one of the rare places where people still wear fur coats,
you know,
not ironically or fake,
but real fur coat.
Well,
if you wear a fur coat in La,
first of all,
it's never hold it off for a fur coat.
But if you did,
you might get fucked up,
like thrown on you.
Some shit could go down.
You know,
like you,
you most likely nothing's going to happen,
but there's a possible chance,
which is really,
because if you wear a leather
jacket,
you have no problem.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I mean,
Aspen's weird because a lot of the Thompson's friends like Lauren Jenkins,
a great journalist,
um,
they've moved down to basalt,
they'd say down valley.
So I was out there with his,
um,
his son,
Juan Thompson,
is a fantastic writer.
He wrote a book called,
um,
stories I tell myself about his relationship with his father in contact with
Juan through email.
He's a really good writer and he's a really honest and brilliant writer.
He seems like a good dude and he seemed like a really good dude in the Gonzo
documentary as well.
That was a great document.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of kidney.
He,
he always kills it.
I,
um,
I went to the,
uh,
the tavern and woody creek when I wasn't,
I felt like if I'm here I gotta go.
I gotta go there.
Yeah.
Was Weird.
It's weird being there,
man.
When did you go?
How long ago was that?
This was a year ago.
You're now where people on bicycles just,
uh,
riding their bikes by the whole time.
It's on this huge bike route now.
It was cold as fuck.
It was the winter.
We were there for a ski trip.
So what did you think of it while it was just cool?
You know,
it's like there's places you go to where you just,
uh,
you just Kinda,
you know,
I was with my family.
They didn't give a fuck.
My kids have no idea who he is.
The children listen to hear or need to know who he is and children to help my
kids learn eventually,
but they're just eating enchiladas.
You know,
but it's just,
um,
it's uh,
to me it represented a big part of who he,
you know,
this is like this is home base.
He came out to San Francisco and here's a picture of me there.
I think there's a picture of me there on my Instagram.
I was this special place from when he was in San Francisco was like being on the
central nerve.
He was there from 64 to 67 and [inaudible] 66 and he saw the first Jefferson
airplane concert right next to the matrix.
He went out every night until like 5:00 AM this is what the hell's angels.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I got hammered there to respect
quite a few Margarita is here.
He could divide his life up.
Look,
the free power,
if you see in the background that freak power,
um,
the,
yeah,
the sheriff's a campaign symbol,
but he moved at Woody Creek and he suddenly had you see it in his,
um,
you see it when you interview people that knew him.
You see it in his letters.
He had space again.
And being in the city was hard for him because he can write beautifully about
the hell's angels,
about the countercultural scene.
He was at war protests and the free speech movement with Mario Savio,
he was there,
but it was burning him up.
You know,
it was using him up.
And I think when you went to Woody Creek,
he learned that all right,
I can take a plane to Chicago,
he kicked my ass kicked,
but I can come back and if I want to have a drink I can go to that tavern or I
can go to the Jerome Hotel.
And that's a good space.
And I think that was a good space for him.
Yep.
Well I think that's a,
probably a very intelligent move on his behalf.
And a lot of us,
I think that are involved in day to day chaos would probably benefit from
something similar.
I mean,
I just don't think he gets enough credit for his effort.
You know,
one thing I've found when reading the book I interviewed,
um,
and if he'd Bob Geiger,
who fair is dedicated to and who was a doctor,
that it was a friend of his in Sonoma and Geiger initially was the one
prescribed dexedrine.
And so people think Thompson was just doing acid in writing or whatever and
maybe later as a caricature,
whoever he became that might've been part of his persona.
But when he was reading from the book is from Kennedy's assassination to Nixon's
resignation,
he was working so fucking hard,
like he was working harder than we can ever imagine.
Douglas Brinkley is,
um,
the presidential historian who does his literary estate talks about Thompson
wasn't as fun as he seemed during that time.
He took dexedrine to write and he had a drinking problem.
I'm having is some sort of an amphetamine.
It's Adderall,
Adderall,
that's cut differently with salt.
So it's a little bit like you go a little higher and it,
when it comes down it's a little harder.
Well,
Adderall was Oba trawl,
which was an old diet drug and that was repurposed in like 96.
That is a little bit smoother in that sense,
but it's very similar to what a two what Thompson took.
He had a great editor named Margaret Harel who was his editor on Hell's angels
and he didn't know she was 27 when he was 29 he thought she was like 55 cause
they would talk on the phone every day to edit the book and he sent her,
she still has the letter.
I've done something events with her.
She still has the actual letter.
He sent her a five milligram dexedrine.
He's like,
hey,
it's going to be hard the last 10 pages to edit,
take this and focus.
So she still has it.
This orange,
he'll five milligram dexedrine for 40 50 years she's had.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
that gives me,
documentary is a really fantastic,
it's probably one of the best introductions that anybody could have to try to
get a grip on.
Why after all these years,
a hundred resonates with so many people.
I mean,
I think that the giving you documentary is brilliantly and perfectly done.
I think the Thompson means something different with Donald Trump as president of
the United States.
To me,
you people could see before given the taught before,
other like,
um,
brilliant writers sought before.
[inaudible] did.
But when Donald Trump became president of the United States,
it was a lens onto the past I felt like.
And I was uh,
I mean I'm a bitch ass liberal.
Like I was fucking upset.
And so one of the ways I dealt with it was to just remove myself to 1968,
1967,
1969.
And I took the emotion I had and the present and I realized that Thompson is,
is such a voice right now for people that maybe don't know him,
only know him through fear and loathing in Las Vegas,
Terry Gilliam's film,
I would like freaking do to be a lens that now if they read that they could then
read his work and perhaps you know what his timelessness will come through.
It was more,
it was an attempt to focus that timelessness and that what helped was the
fucking terror of our present.
Yeah.
You can see the definitely see the parallels and in his work,
you know who also a rings true like that is a lot of Bill Hicks stuff on the
first Gulf War,
you know,
and,
and Bush as a president and you know,
butch,
obviously people today would probably be dying to have bushes president,
you know,
the original Bart,
he carried his book around for two weeks at least to carry the book.
Well,
Herbert Walker,
the main,
the older Bush who was,
uh,
you know,
much more of a reasonable gentlemen,
you know.
Yeah.
Well that's our discourse today too.
Were there couldn't be anything said reasonably about him when he passed away or
even about his wife.
I mean,
I think it's not,
he's not very favorable right now,
but one of the hundred Thompson's main influences was Norman mailer.
And I don't think Norman mailer rights well about women.
You know,
I think that's,
I think Thompson wrote better about women.
Thompson didn't just,
what's the red bubbles him,
but I'm not familiar with.
Well,
Malin,
whenever he writes about a woman,
it's like he's watching the Nixon Nets get off the Nixon airplane.
And he's like,
there were 33 redheads,
like five had long legs like this.
Like it's like,
man,
like you didn't need to write that fucking passage.
You're writing about power and people more extreme than you.
So I think Miller writes beautifully about men that have more power than him.
And so he writes about 1968 Chicago,
we're Thompson didn't cause Thompson was beat up and he writes about that moment
of,
um,
we're Thompson's being beat up.
I'm confused.
But what does the criticism of the way he's writing about women?
Just he's describing them physically.
Uh,
the male gaze is that he will,
he stabbed his wife.
He stabbed his wife in the heart.
Did he really?
Yeah.
With the pen knife.
What?
Yeah,
he went to Bellevue.
He went to Bellevue for 14 days.
It was in 19 six.
That's it.
He missed it.
Yeah.
No,
he went to,
he did a psychiatrist.
A psychiatric evaluation instead of going to jail.
Well,
I think they stayed married,
but yeah.
Well I want a reasonable lady.
So gender politics later.
But I would say that Thompson wrote well better about women because he
understood that running about people with more power than you is really
important.
And when mailer writes about people with more power than him,
when he writes about Mayor Daley beating the shit out of everybody,
he writes really beautifully.
And that's somebody that's resonating right now with what Trump's doing.
And with the violence that we're seeing on the right.
And on the left were mailer was sitting with a Pat Buchanan who was Nixon's main
aid.
Um,
and during that moment in Chicago in the Haymarket in shattered and everybody
was beat up and they were looking down from the 17th floor and mailers thinking
like,
well this is what happens if police take over society.
And he writes beautifully about how the police came and split the protesters
because he's so high up writing it.
It's gorgeous.
And you can end would write later.
Like I knew that Nixon was going to be president of the United States because of
fucking Hubert Humphrey that cutlass hold ward heeler can't control his own
convention and his own party.
How is he going to be able to run the country?
And so as soon as Chicago's violence erupted,
the Nixon campaign knew they'd won the election.
Patty.
And it's really interesting because even though a hunter would shit on him,
pappy Canon,
they were freshly fan.
No,
they drank,
they drank at the Watergate.
Like they sat there and went deep like all night.
But he definitely,
hunter definitely shit on him.
Oh,
he shit on them hard.
That'd be Kinda Shit back on him hard.
The first night they met was at the Nixon.
I'm at the w at the Holiday Inn in 1968 in New Hampshire during Nixon's come
back campaign and Thompson walks in and peck peck,
he can't,
he goes,
who's this damn guy with the damn ski jacket walking through our Goddamn lobby
and Tufts.
It's like,
I have a press pass,
like I'm here to do this.
And so they like have this big moment.
And then later on that night Thompson goes to a party with,
um,
campaign people and with,
uh,
Heenan and he brings a big bottle of wild Turkey.
And so we can,
as a young journalist at the time he worked at the Saint Louis Post dispatch,
I think he'd gone to the Columbia journalism school is working for Nixon.
This is main policy guy and he looks at Toms.
He's like,
that's the fucking the ski.
Oh you got a bottle of Wa.
Oh if you've got a file it old crow,
like no little drink that.
Instead they stayed up all night and they talked about the Vietnam War and
Thompson,
you know,
talked about how it does figures us to be in a foreign war that's unjust and it
destroys our democratic ideals to be doing that and became was like containment,
nuclear war.
We're trying to get out of it and they listened to each other until dawn,
like that first night that they met now.
What was your idea behind writing this book?
Like what?
What compelled you?
I think we've mistaken Thompson.
I think that we see them more as like a Doonesbury character.
I think people who know him really well don't.
But I think that most people through whatever cultural forces that we've had,
those legacies and boys,
because a lot of people don't know the comparison what the Doonesbury.
So I think in the eighties or seventies,
eighties,
nineties,
that cartoon Doonesbury by Gary Trudeau,
it became,
there was a character on it called Uncle Duke.
And Uncle Duke was based on Hunter Thompson and he was kind of an exaggerated
version of Hunter Thompson.
He was a cartoonish version of hunters Thompson.
And I think Terry Gilliam did a wonderful and kind of a tourist job on,
um,
uh,
like a brilliant job on fear and loathing in Las Vegas.
But that's also an exaggerated version of Hunter Thompson.
And we forget today the amount of work a hundred Thompson did,
the effort he put out,
we forget that he was a straight journalist where he did the freelance
assignments.
He wrote the straight articles for years to make money for his family.
And it wasn't until he had his breakthrough with hell's angels that he could
develop the style that we identify with today.
And so it kills me that we identify him more as a clown or like a,
you know,
more as a,
a cartoonish figure as opposed to a very serious political thinker,
political activist and serious writer who can give us insight into the fucking
shit show we experience every moment today.
Well,
I think the,
the perception of him is fairly nuanced.
I don't think that everybody thinks of him as a cartoon character,
although particularly later on in his life,
he was relegated to that because he really didn't speak well.
You know,
later on his life when he was just,
the drugs had taken over alcohol and the alcohol his son writes about the
alcohol.
One writes so beautifully about the toll.
Alcoholism took on hunter s Thompson.
We couldn't talk anymore.
I mean,
when he was deep into his sixties is our bars of them.
Sarah,
it was so hard to even understand him.
There's a awful piece that he did with Conan O'brien or Conan,
went to a woody creek and shotguns,
uh,
off the back porch with him and you could barely understand a fucking word
hunter saying,
that's why I tried to end it with Nixon leaving because it was really sad when
Nixon resigned.
100.
Thompson was at the Connecticut Hilton,
which is a hotel right by the White House.
Any Liebowitz,
um,
the photographer with rolling stone was calling him and saying,
we need to get to the White House.
Nixon is a leaving,
like he's going to get on the,
and Thompson
just laid in the grass and he didn't go,
you know,
and that was heartbreaking.
And he didn't end up writing the eight page spread that he needed to.
Instead,
it became,
Annie Liebowitz is photography,
which was a famous and,
um,
in retrospect,
like huge move for her career.
But I think that that pain right there of thinking that he'd spent 10 years,
I mean,
he hated Nixon since the checkers speech,
you know,
and Nixon was the VP for Eisenhower.
He hated Nixon since 1962 when Nixon lost the California,
um,
uh,
governor ship and said,
you and the press,
you've been giving me the shaft for so long,
like you won't have Dick Nixon to kick around anymore.
Like Thompson had seen that Nixon was somebody who said,
I'm just the poor son of a butcher.
I'm just this like very hardworking,
you know,
American that represents all of us were be behind that.
Like he was a politically,
um,
you know,
ravenous monster who was anticommunist who would go to any extent to win.
And Thompson saw that and Thompson knew that other people saw in,
in 1964,
the Barry Goldwater convention in San Francisco,
my favorite Lee named arena of all time,
the cow palace.
Um,
Barry Goldwater was going to speak to accept the nomination.
And what happened was Nixon was introducing them.
It was Nixon's way back from the wilderness.
Thompson was a few rows back.
The first time.
Thompson I think was that close to see him live.
And Nixon was like,
you know,
poor son of a butcher.
Don't think about me.
Just think about Barry Goldwater.
Mr Conservative who become Mr President.
And Thompson was like,
fuck everybody here knows he's lying.
What they think that that act of lying is a skill and the way a used car
salesman who lies but can make a lot of money off.
It was skillful the way that Trump by selling steaks to people and then they go
bankrupt and he gets rich.
That's an American skill and Thompson sense that from the start with Nixon.
And so I think he battled against Nixon for a decade,
for a lot of years.
And when Nixon left,
I think he felt spent.
And so I tried not to focus on the later,
you know,
I ended then in [inaudible] 74 because I think it's,
he wrote some beautiful things afterwards,
still
aggressively.
He definitely had some moments where he decided to not do the assignment that he
was supposed to do.
And it was kinda sad.
Like I'm the Ali foreman fight.
Fucking floated in the pool.
Yeah.
Float in the pool with a Nixon mask on,
flew all the way to Africa and miss one of the greatest sports moments.
It was like six of 'em,
you know,
um,
the Boston red sox versus the reds.
I think Ali was something different to people then.
I think it's,
I don't think we have someone like that today.
So it's very difficult for us to understand if people today look at Ali and
they'd go,
oh,
he was a heavyweight boxing champion.
He was way more than that.
He was,
uh,
a cultural figure that represented the resistance to the Vietnam War and
represented it with the biggest loss that any public figure it ever shown and
willingly gave up three years of his career in his prime from age 27 to 30.
From 1967 from the Cleveland Big Cat Williams.
He
didn't fight again for three years.
He didn't train.
He didn't do anything.
They kept him from his career.
Why?
When he was in his prime,
when he was the best heavyweight of all time,
and he spoke publicly and often,
and we was fucking hate it all over the country.
But he represented something different.
Like,
uh,
my parents were hippies and when I was a little kid,
he lost to Leon Spinks and the rematch was on talent.
Shit.
My parents never watched TV and they definitely never watched boxing.
And they,
they,
they sat in front of that TV to watch that.
I remember thinking,
I can't believe my parents want to watch a boxing match.
Like this is crazy.
And I was probably like,
I don't know,
maybe eight or nine years old or something at the time.
And I just remember thinking,
I can't believe my parents want to watch a boxing match.
And that's where really when it's sunk into me at a really early age,
that this guy was not just this heavyweight boxer.
He was,
he was,
uh,
a cultural icon.
He was a historical figure.
He meant he meant a lot.
And to hunter,
he met a lot.
He meant something,
something much bigger than just just a boxer.
And so hunter thought he was going to a death sentence.
George Foreman had crushed Joe Frazier.
He crushed everybody.
I mean,
he was so powerful.
George Foreman to this day is one of the all time scariest heavyweights.
Wall time without a doubt.
He,
he could hit so fucking hard and literally pick guys off their feet.
He hit Joe Frazier and lifted him off his feet with a punch and uh,
everybody was convinced that was going to happen to Ali that Ali had been past
its prime.
And look,
just look at what George Foreman had done to Joe Frazier.
What is he going to do to Muhammad Ali and Ali just rope a dope them until he
got tired and then fucked him up in front of the whole world.
This is one of the greatest athletic moments.
I mean we forget that athletes,
athletes like curt flood,
you know,
they,
they risked.
Who's that weight?
Curt flood was the American baseball player who challenged the reserve clause
cause it baseball.
You weren't allowed to get free agency for another team.
And curt flood was this great player and he was like,
I'm going to sit out and I'm going to wait.
Athletes like Colin Kaepernick,
they've sacrificed that career.
It's not the same with Muhammad Ali who was like Babe Ruth and Barry bonds and
like any money combined at that one moment.
Right.
But he was risking,
it's the opposite of Trump.
Trump used his celebrity to become this even more mangled version of himself and
get more power.
They use his celebrity to speak for his virtue in his value and his beliefs and
sat like Thomson was really good at understanding what people sacrifice.
But people have to give up the wager,
you know,
between what that act will be,
what the results will be.
They may be later,
but he knew that.
And so his respect for Ali for giving up those years of his prime,
you know,
was,
was enduring.
He Keep Thompson came back from that fight and he gave his son on one a boxing
gloves,
um,
that,
or we're,
uh,
at least boxing gloves.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's a very,
very unfortunate that he missed out fight because it would have been fascinating
to hear his take on it.
To me.
I'm sure he would've been so moved.
20 saw Ali win,
but it wasn't,
I mean that's a good point.
It was indicative of I think the stress and the pressure that the last decade of
covering Nixon had taken out on him.
Well,
there's a little bit of that,
but let's be honest,
he was also kind of a fuck up.
I mean when he was writing for rolling stone and they gave him that,
that early fax machine show.
Yeah,
and he would fuck that thing up.
You would unplug it and plug it back in.
He would do it just so he could go to the bar and say,
this thing doesn't work.
But that was the end.
I think of his arc where he was still on point.
He was still playing the role of a serious journalist and he would use that
persona as a fuckup and there's letters by yon winter being like,
you cannot turn in your articles three hours before we go to press.
I know you made it.
This doesn't fucking work.
And so he was beginning to break down.
Then he was also,
I think on the tail end of his decade of being a journalist who had met every
deadline so that he could fucking feed his family and he could afford how far,
like there were moments where he wouldn't before he got the,
um,
contract for hell's angels in 1965 he was ready to be like a longshoreman.
He was going and looking for work in the mornings in San Francisco,
you know,
to try to support his family.
He was willing to give up writing and instead that article blew up and he,
all these beautiful letters began to arrive at three 19 Parnassus where he lived
at,
um,
at the top of the Haight Ashbury and I'm San Francisco and you know,
that opened up his chance to continue being a writer,
but money was the main motivating factor.
And so I think once money like unfurled,
once alcoholism I think took its toll and once he couldn't walk around anymore
attic political camp convention without people just like grabbing his shoulder
and saying,
you're a hunter Thompson.
As that happened,
I think things began to change.
Yeah.
That's one of the things that he talked about that I thought was really
interesting that he became a part of the story.
It wasn't just that he was covering stories,
he couldn't be anonymous anymore.
He was in many cases,
more famous in the people that he was covering.
Yeah.
You know,
like when he would go to meet Nixon,
all Nikki Nixon,
secret service agents wanted to meet him and they wanted us to get an autograph
from him and shake his hand and it was just too weird.
Everything had got.
And then there's the alcoholism,
alcoholism.
Look it,
it's a depressant.
It wrecks you.
And if you read,
you know,
we,
me and Greg Fitzsimmons on a podcast once read off,
uh,
that one journalist who had a detailed hunters daily routine.
And so we,
we read the daily routine and they put a techno beat to it.
It's fucking hilarious.
That was a bad,
that's a set.
Those are so,
it's so funny because those seem funny,
you know now,
but they're kind of the death knell.
Like,
I mean that,
that daily routine,
um,
that was,
the,
the biography hunter,
it was in that and it's just,
it's heartbreaking.
I mean,
we've got to remember that the dedication to fear and loathing in Las Vegas was
he who makes a beast of himself gets rid of the pain man.
And I think the world was painful for a Hunter Thompson and it was painful to
see powerful people abused the week,
you know,
and like take what they wanted brazenly without being held accountable.
I think it hard to deal with shitty editors
who cut half your fucking essay on Nixon or half her story and made it into
something that had nothing to do with the effort that you put out.
You know,
I think it was hard to pay your bills and you know,
live the way that you wanted to live.
And I think a lot of that gets undermined.
I just want people to realize how much effort he put out,
especially during those years where he was like,
all right,
I want to be a great journalist.
I want to have a voice in our society.
I want to participate in our national conversation.
My only path towards that is to work harder than everybody else to be at places
when things happen and when they matter.
And he sacrificed a lot for that,
but he was there and he's a voice in a light that we can have in this moment,
which is another troubling moment in American history.
Yeah.
His voice was very unique too,
in that he decided to combine fiction with nonfiction in a very weird,
blurry way.
I think it was.
So one thing I think of is he usually gives you a cue where what he did was he
dramatize,
people didn't dramatize [inaudible] shit up.
He didn't just dramatize.
There's a rumor.
It's doctor,
I didn't say that he did able gate.
I said there was,
this is about Ed Muskie's campaign.
Um,
I said there was a rumor in Milwaukee that he did up again.
I started that rumor.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's what he says,
but what did he said that on the Dick Cavett show?
Yeah.
Later.
And I think Matt Taibbi on this show talked about it.
Well where my thing is that,
um,
muskie was already out of the campaign.
When that came out,
muskie had already lost.
And so muskie had been a fucking monster and a terrible person on that campaign.
And so Thompson use that version of Musky and wrote,
as Toby said,
in a very straight way,
the Ibogaine story.
And so if you had a sense of irony,
you kind of knew,
like you're not really thinking that this is a guy who did able gain.
So I think there's queues in there for our listening audience.
But what I think is even more,
uh,
you know what,
I think he dramatize the way other people didn't.
He would say,
I look left,
I look up,
I see.
He came down to me and then he said,
people didn't write like that in journalism.
They didn't go step by step.
And he did.
And that was really important.
What I think is more important than the Ibogaine story.
So the biggest story in the background is Ed Muskie was the front runner for the
Democratic primary in 1972.
He fucked up his campaign afterwards.
Thompson talked about how he had heard that there are,
there was a rumor that this candidate was doing,
it began,
which is like Iowasca or he said no,
it's not like Iowasca it's not,
no,
it's very different.
So hallucinatory,
it's a self examined Tori.
I was the one who get off,
get off.
Yeah.
Um,
but he said they brought in a Brazilian,
which yeah,
Ibogaine is not even a Brazilian drugs from Africa,
but what I think people don't remember is before that and this affected the
election.
And um,
February of 1972 Thompson was in Florida.
He was on something called the sunshine special.
It was a whistle stop tour that Musky,
the front runner had a good chance to beat Nixon,
pull numbers wise,
um,
was um,
going all the way down the Florida peninsula on to try to win the Florida
primary.
And Thompson was like,
this is the most disgusting thing I've ever seen.
Like at every stop Musky give the same shit speech.
It's like somebody should be your president,
namely me.
And it was repeated.
The reporters were like,
fucking,
this is terrible.
Muskie was secluded in the back of the car.
He didn't interact with anybody.
They had his,
um,
political operatives come out and make everybody like sing the song like,
about like Musky,
like sunshine in his hands,
the whole world in his hands.
It was terrible.
And so that night Thompson pulled into a Florida town.
It was the second to last stop and he and this young political reporter named
Monte Chitty where I'm going to get a drink at 2:00 AM and this guy walks into
the lobby.
He's like six,
six,
two 50 Peter Sheridan.
And he,
um,
he walks in and he,
he says he's looking for the muskie campaign,
all these different things.
He ends up going out with them a hundred tops in for a drink and a hundred
Thompson finds out that Peter Sheridan had been a good friend of Jerry Garcia,
had hung out with the hell's angels in California,
had been to the Honda,
where can Casey was and was actually a pretty smart guy who was out of his mind
in his mid twenties.
They stayed out and drink all night at the end of the night.
Thompson's like,
so what are you doing tomorrow?
Where you going?
And Peter Sharon was like,
well,
I'm going to Miami and thumps.
It's like we are too.
You don't have to hitchhike.
Fuck that.
And so there's a really good journalist.
I'm outlaw.
Um,
it's called,
uh,
um,
journalists by bill McKean,
the tea,
another Thompson biography.
It talks about how Thompson took his thumbs and took his press pass,
put it into the elevator,
press the button,
sent the press pass down to the ground floor.
Peter shared in,
got it.
So Peter Sheridan could ride for free on the Sunshine Express Down to Miami the
next day.
So Thompson over sleeps because the fucking muskie campaign doesn't like him.
Anyways,
instead Peter Sheridan gets on the sunshine express with a Hunter Thompson Press
Badge and Peter Sheridan goes on to order 12 martinis and he goes,
give me like a triple gin bucks.
Hold the buck.
And he runs up and down the car.
And you know,
Musky has been a really shitty candidate at this point.
He's not been engaging people.
He got in this weird fight with his wife at am a campaign event where they like
put cake in each other's face.
It's been really weird and people aren't reporting on it,
like other reporters aren't saying muskies unstable.
And so Musky at the end of this whistle stop,
he spent all his campaign money to go up and down and try to do this whistle
stop tour.
He gives the speech,
the caboose and Jerry Ruben,
the antiwar activist who was,
what are the Chicago seven,
um,
and was um,
it has come to heckle him,
is in the crowd and he's saying to mosquito,
so why did you support the Vietnam War in 1968?
Like,
who do you think you are?
And so muskies yelling at Jerry Ruben,
he's saying,
young man,
keep your mouth shut beneath Musky reaching up from the bottom of that caboose.
Peter Sheridan is holding a gin bottle and grabbing it muskies leg as Musky
tries to give the speech and then Musky falls back in.
The whole thing ends like the whole press conferences over like women's wear
daily reported this and it came out that Hunter Thompson had had 13 Martinis and
run up and down the train and had interfered with it and Muskie's campaign
really believed that Thompson was working with Donald Segretti and Nixon's um,
creep,
um,
Watergate crew to fuck up muskie's campaign.
And that actually changed the course.
It like Thompson help expose how fucked up muskie was as a candidate at that
time.
And Thompson had never forgiven Musky for being on the pro Vietnam War Platform
at the 1968 convention.
And so we talk about the implicate aspect of changing the campaign,
but that report and the way that disseminated through media,
the way it was picked up by other newspapers really did help change the people's
perception of Ed Muskie,
big Ed Muskie as a top to call them at the time.
No,
he,
when he wrote Hell's angels,
he hadn't really totally formulated that sort of Gonzo style of journalism,
but he did have a little bit of fiction mixed in with that and that sort of ran
him a foul of the hell a hell's angels.
They were very upset by that.
Right?
Like he,
he did write some things in there that they claim or not
accurate.
I think that when it came to hell's angels,
um,
what Thompson did really well is what Joan Didion did really well.
He took the way the media was portraying somebody and he strip that off and
said,
this is who they actually are.
This is what they're actually doing.
Joan Didion,
when she writes about Jim Morrison and the white album,
she's like,
Jim Morrison was like sex and death in his leather pants was the best thing
ever.
Everybody loves Jim Morrison.
And then in the scene and the white album,
Joan Didion writes about how they sit at a recording studio for two hours and
nobody says anything and they eat eggs out of a paper bag and it's a fucking
nightmare.
Thompson knew that the media was sensationalizing the hell's angels.
He went to them,
um,
on a cold night in San Francisco.
I'm down by the waterfront.
And he said,
hey,
here's a Newsweek article.
Here's a time article.
Here's how everybody's running about you.
All I want to do is write the truth about who you are.
And he did.
And he ended up writing with them.
Um,
and he ended up spending time with them.
I don't think they got as mad at him about the way he portrayed them.
I think they got mad that he began to make money or that he became famous.
Hell's angels sold 500,000 paperback copies.
That is almost impossible to imagine today.
500,000 people about copies of a literary book.
And the angels were pissed off about that.
They felt Thompson owed him more money or owed him something for that.
Did he to them at all?
Did he give them any money?
Eddie Barker,
sunny burgers.
So ridiculously buggers said he owed us a keg and he didn't give us a cake.
That's it.
You know,
and the,
the famous story at the end of it is that that is,
I mean really like when they go through it,
he said that he said the Thompson was doing a subjective version of us,
but it was at least close to then the shitty Newsweek and time versions.
And so Thompson at the end of,
he'd finished the book,
barely made the deadline.
I had to go down to a hotel and Monterey lock himself in step for a hundred
hours straight and write it in March of [inaudible] 67 to finish it.
So it turns it in,
makes it is um,
advanced deadline in September.
They're like,
here's our author photo and it's Shitty.
And he's like,
fuck this.
So he goes to a hell's angels rally.
He know anybody because he hasn't been with them for six or seven months.
He's taking pictures.
That's when he got freed up for writing about the hell's angels and he tiny his
friend who later committed suicide after Altima after being involved in the
ultimate security situation.
Tyler rolling stone one where the younger stuff,
yes,
where Meredith hunter was stabbed but tiny.
It was a woman that got stabbed,
a man,
Meredith hunter.
Oh.
Um,
it was a man named Meredith.
It was back in the day where you can name your kid's Meredith,
right?
Like Marion,
Marion's another one.
Right.
Lindsey,
Lindsey.
Some guys were Lindsey to speak.
Gimme one Jamie.
Oh yeah.
But Jamie's normal.
Well,
if there's a lot of January's a future man scene where it's like,
what's his name is like,
my name is Susan in the future mentor named Susan.
I know it's a girl's name and your time.
Um,
but her death is a weird one though.
You must hate your fucking saw in the mail,
but lose an argument with your wife.
But that
I've lost a lot of,
but that poor guy was,
um,
but Thompson was there and tiny grabbed him after he was beat up.
There's a guy holding a rock to drop it on.
Thompson with the hell's angels.
And tiny was like,
all right,
I know him.
I know the rest of you don't.
And he grabbed him out and tiny.
Was this like enormous hell's angel who had been,
you know,
Thompson Weisberg good at empathetically understanding their flaws and their
perspectives.
He'd never,
I think made excuses for him.
He said that their inherent perspective as fascistic,
he writes that,
you know,
he says they use violence to respond to where they weren't society.
The idea of total retaliation.
The hell's angels were any offense like looking at you funny or being like due
to drink.
It could be met with everybody beating you up.
Cause they got to determine the,
they got the hell's angels got to determine the offense.
Like that was fascism to Thompson and he wrote beautifully about their reliance
on violence cause he,
they felt the hell's angels.
They'd been left behind by our moderated society.
Like there's technology,
there's all these new jobs.
If you came back from the war in 1950 you had a chance in Oakland to have a
middle class life and a beautiful house in work the rest of your days and have a
family that will then go on.
But by 1965,
that was no longer an option.
And the angels were a violent response to that.
Very similar to what we're seeing now.
And so the way he wrote about the hell's angels,
it's very similar to the way that we see violence within groups that are
supporting Trump.
You know,
it's going to lift and the right.
Did he ever wind up resolving his differences with the hell's angels?
I think so.
Sunny Margaret healthy angels got fucked.
Like rightly so.
The hell's angels were,
you know,
pursued like a mob.
Um,
like a,
like a Mafia group.
People went to jail,
sunny barker went to jail.
Um,
I think they at the end appreciated his representation of them because it was
better than any other ones.
There's no better representation of the house.
Ain't no more sympathetic for sure.
Are just no more accurate.
No more understood.
Yeah,
no more like,
again,
I guess the Thompsons effort,
if you ride for six months with somebody and you're an honest,
like putting up your hands,
you're not trying to fit what you see into a thesis,
you're doing the opposite.
Trying to look at the reality you have in front of you and then form an argument
out of that.
You could hear it.
That's what Thompson's gift was.
And very dangerous too to do that.
I mean,
he didn't get beat up taking those photographs,
really bad motorcycle accident with his friend on the pack and his friend broke
his leg.
Like it was just,
we're tough.
That's why he left.
He's like,
get the fuck out of San Francisco.
Yeah.
Chris looks amazing.
Like temperatures.
It's amazing.
It's a,
it's a fire that you're putting your hand on to.
How can burnt ash?
He was coming down.
Um,
it was with the mayor of Richmond.
He was coming down as slick road and they had,
um,
hit,
uh,
like something was wet or an oil thing and it went out the back tire.
So Thompson rolled it was fine,
but his friends knee hit,
um,
railroad tracks.
So there's friends need broke really badly.
Um,
it was the mayor,
it was the mayor of Richmond and that's continued riding motorcycles though.
I,
yeah,
he did.
He would get in accidents at Woody Creek,
but he was pretty careful like,
so I love that scene in Hell's angels.
I don't know if readers,
our listeners know this,
but the edge,
you know,
and that's a major part of the book where Thompson's fighting with his wife,
Thompson's finished his book,
but he's breaking down because he's worked so hard to do it.
And so he takes his,
um,
Bsa out and he goes,
if you know San Francisco,
he goes out to the park,
he hits the Coast highway and he comes down and he's like,
I'm so overwhelmed.
Everything is so fucking terrible.
He's going as fast as he can.
And he talks about how his eyes began to lose moisture.
You,
you know the scene,
it's this beautiful scene.
He's looking for sand pits cause he hit a sandpit near the zoo.
You're fucking.
Dot.
Yeah.
And he gets all the way to Rockaway beach,
which is in like halfway down to Santa Cruz.
And he turns around and when he talks about is when he's at a hundred miles per
hour and I think he was near death and he was really overwhelmed.
He says,
you know,
the edge,
the only people that know it are the people that have gone over the rest,
the living,
don't have any understanding of that.
And all we can do is approach it in this way.
And it's this beautiful and it's called midnight and the coast highway,
it was a anthologized and Tom Wolfe,
you know,
and it was just beautiful.
So he comes back and he sits at his desk and so he,
he had a view of the bay bridge,
he could see it's two flashing lights the whole time.
And he had broken the window in a terrible fight with his wife like three weeks
earlier.
Um,
and so he sits the broken window and he writes out that scene right away with
his eyes still scoured of voicing the broken window when she wouldn't give him a
gun cause he was on acid and he threw a shoe through the window.
There's three,
there's three versions.
So I do it and then I give the three versions of the notes.
So I go with the three versions that I've heard.
Like I heard it from her,
you know,
she wrote,
I really respect sandy like deeply.
She wrote it the um,
uh,
a few years ago she said,
I'm done giving interviews about Ana's Thompson.
That was my life that it was then.
She's given so many interviews up to this point.
She says that that exists.
And so I wanted to respect that more than anything and just use the information
that I had or know and let the reader know,
Yo,
here at three other versions,
here's the best version I could make.
Dramatize,
look left,
throw,
do this.
Did you talk to Anita?
Anita has been great.
I had to talk to,
we need a little bit.
The book ended so early that I did,
there's a beautiful art as his second wife for homes and need a Thompson is um,
she runs Al Farm.
She runs kind of his legacy.
She does the Facebook page.
She has a wonderful job on what is our farm today.
Does she still live up there and she's going to make it into a,
like a writer's retreat.
She's doing a one off job,
make it into a writer's retreat and also a,
um,
like a museum and it's taken a while but to honor his legacy as a great
political thinker and writer,
like a great literary light.
But since she didn't meet him until the 90s,
I wanted to focus on the time that I was in.
Um,
and so I,
I think talking to Bob Geiger,
you know,
his friend then was,
was really,
I was really lucky.
I'll go here.
He's in his late eighties,
and he was able to go through like,
cause I had,
I believe if you interview somebody,
you need to read everything that exists already.
You need to read everything they've already said.
You don't want to ask them questions that when I do interview for research that
they've already supplied answers to them.
So with Bob Geiger,
I could see the holes or things I didn't know and I was able to sit with him,
talk about throwing a football with Thompson,
talk about taking the dog to the beach,
like all these other things.
That's the football thing is an interesting thing cause he was who's obsessed
with football and that's one thing that he shared in common with Nixon.
And so when they went one time they were going to the airport and he hits to
ride with Nixon and Nixon wanted to talk to him about football and he said,
let's just not talk about politics when we talk about football.
And so he talks to my favorite,
the whole ride.
It was,
it was in 1968 Pat Buchanan had helped set it up.
They did out that week they'd become friends.
And so they come to Thompson,
they're like,
all right,
the boss is going to take a plane to Florida.
You can come and talk to him.
And so later Thompson said later,
it was like,
they told me not to talk about anything but football.
But earlier Thompson said like,
I was just really awkward.
Like this fucking guy.
They're both in the back bench of a mercury and so it's before secret service.
So it's just a cop driving and it's like pappy candidate in the front and it's
Thompson and Nixon and they're right here next to each other.
And Thompson's like ledge.
You know,
earlier in the night you'd said that,
you know,
the Oakland Raiders had a good shot to beat the packers and Superbowl too.
Can you talk about that?
And he was like,
Dick's is like my good friend Vince Lombardi had told me to watch out for the
AFL cause they pass and they can be very effective.
And so Thompson then like remembers that guy.
Um,
um,
Bob Geiger had been a professional quarterback.
He had taken Thompson to his first football game and Thompson said NFL is better
than the AFL and Geiger's like,
shut the fuck up,
let's go to a Raiders game.
And they went and 65 and the Raiders won on this beautiful pass,
Tom Tom Flores,
like beautiful goal line pass.
And Nixon was saying the same thing.
And so then at that moment,
at that moment Thompson's like,
oh yeah,
it was the Miami Guy,
uh,
Miller Miller who'd caught the pass in Nixon,
Gus Thompson and on the knee and Gus,
you're right and goes,
oh,
what a beautiful moment and tops.
It's just like,
what the fuck is going on?
So Nixon apparently they were talking about like college draft picks and all
kinds of crazy shit.
Like Nixon was deep into it.
It was the only moment Thompson said that he knew Nixon wasn't lying.
They can talk about football and that in that instance,
it's fascinating when people,
they're so diametrically to each other,
but they find common ground.
Thompson did a great job of that and I think we've lost it today.
I mean,
you have to listen to the other side to,
if you,
if you politically want to beat somebody like flat pappy cannon,
he wanted defeat his tactics.
If you wanted to feed him,
you need to know how he's thinking and what he's doing.
It Thompson knew that Makina was listening to the left to defeat them.
And so Thompson listened to be Keenan.
What led him to move to Colorado.
Oh,
he was losing his shit and San Francisco,
it was that night on the fucking motorcycle.
I mean,
but how did he choose Colorado?
So this is a great story.
And like the early sixties,
Thompson had had a chance to drive,
um,
I don't know,
some sort of cargo.
I got friends car out to Colorado on his way to San Francisco in 1960 he ended
up doing a road trip up and down San Francisco after he passed through Colorado.
But he stopped in Colorado because he had to drop off a friend's car.
And there was a woman there,
Peggy Clifford,
who was a journalist and was his good friend at the,
um,
at the Aspen Daily Times.
And she was older.
She saw him like after driving 20 hours,
she's like,
Hey,
come in my house,
hang out.
And she lived right in Aspen and woody creek.
And so then in 1963,
after sandy was pregnant,
Thompson came back from South America where he was a reporter and did a
wonderful job like reporting on how democracies were falling apart down there.
Him and sandy wanted to move west because the national observer was the
newspaper tops worked for.
They wanted to give Thompson,
I'm a position to be at Western reporter.
He was thinking of going to San Francisco,
but instead he chose to stop first.
We're,
Peggy Clifford was stopped in Aspen and Woody Creek.
And so he was living in an aspen and woody creek from August of 1963 to February
of 1963 and he was there,
this is where free kingdom begins.
He was there when John F.
Kennedy was assassinated,
and he sitting in his living room,
it's,
you know,
10:00 AM 11:00 AM Pacific time it,
he gets a knock on the door and it's this rancher named Wayne Vagner,
which is an old aspen family.
And that ranchers like the president's been shot,
like,
what's more,
he was,
he's been murdered,
he's dead.
And Thompson just like,
let's have a Saab.
Then he begins to fucking swear and then he fucking calms down and he goes
downtown Woody Creek,
he goes to aspen and he just gets notes from people what their responses are.
And so when he then went to San Francisco to become the correspondent for,
um,
for,
for the magazine that he was working for,
he was having a tough time.
He was already wanting to flee because he got hell's angels.
He was able to stay in San Francisco longer,
right.
Report on them up in 1966 67.
He was like,
this city is not a good place from,
he has a great quote about like,
what would have happened if he stayed in San Francisco from 67.
[inaudible] he's like,
no,
I would have burned up.
Like I would have been emulated right there.
And so when it was time to leave,
he thought again of Woody Creek and of Aspen,
which was so different than than it is now.
And um,
that was the place that he decided to move and rent for a little while at first.
But then because of the success of Hell's angels,
he was able to buy Alpharma.
Um,
Aspen's very different.
But Woody Creek is not that much different.
Woody Creek is still pretty great though.
The Song Woody Creek are great.
Yeah,
there's a great,
there's a place called the temporary.
They did an event with Juan Thompson and I like did a reading at it and like a
lot of Thompson's friends were there.
So I'm like,
I'm some fucking young.
I didn't know Thompson like I'm an interloper,
you know,
like I'm out there.
And it was really great to talk to everybody that knew him and to go through it.
And that's why I,
that's why this book almost killed me cause I did a note for every sound,
smell our sight or comment,
like if I wrote and then at the moment Thompson felt,
what the fuck am I doing here?
I had the quote where he said,
I looked around then and I felt what the fuck am I doing here?
And I had that in the notes so people could see it.
And it was because I wanted those people that knew him well and respected him
and trusted him to not think that I was in any way trying anything but to make
good art off of his life and who he was trying to respond to.
My fucking view of Trump right now and my love of his work in this moment.
Um,
why,
why do you say it almost killed you?
It's not possible to write a narrative and then also site every detail of a
narrative.
So each day I would spend nine hours researching and outlining with citations.
I wanted to read it like a novel and I want it to be like,
you know,
and at that moment I felt like I in the machine oil from the bay was coming off.
I wanted to read it vividly.
I knew that I had to support all of that.
And so I would spend eight or nine hours every day just on the pure,
um,
arrangement and research.
And then for the next six or seven hours or eight hours,
I would write the narrative and then I'd sleep for five or six hours.
You know,
I get up and I would do it again.
And I did this for four or five months,
you know,
after I was deeply into it.
And I,
I don't think that's sustainable.
I think it's better in retrospect to go and report somewhere,
you know,
to like go and be at the middle of Congress and take notes,
but to try to write something with a dramatize nature that I think Thompson
wrote well and having my pros and saw nothing like his,
you know,
I wanted my pros to sound nothing like the way he wrote,
but then to also have almost as many pages of notes showing my work,
you know,
like showing the math that went behind it.
So if I'm wrong,
I'm wrong,
but at least you can see it.
I think that was morally correct,
but I think that was too much effort when it comes to just because you were
trying to do it in a short period of time.
Did you have a crazy deadline or something?
Yes,
but I also,
I had a year and so,
you know,
and I had a family and I had a,
uh,
um,
a professor,
like I,
I just,
I'd never,
when it came to writing,
had to do both those things,
which was to try to write it in it in a novelistic way.
But then to also make sure that any question the reader would have,
but like,
why did you think that the dinner was at 5:00 PM?
You know,
or like,
you know,
why,
why did you think the sun was coming up in this way at this moment to make sure,
because out of respect,
because with Thompson talked about was people making money off.
I'm like,
Doonesbury yeah.
You know,
like that's what he talked about was people trying to make money on phone.
And if I was gonna have this book,
it could have,
it couldn't be in that space.
Didn't he have a lawsuit against Gary Trudeau?
He thought about it.
I think.
I don't he ever did it.
He talked
about it publicly.
I think it was just well done.
He became that guy.
Unfortunately,
that's what's really weird,
become a caricature of ourselves.
It's really scary.
Do you know,
um,
well it,
it's,
what's weird about it is that he kind of knew that it was happening.
Like there's that famous interview where he's talking to that British guy who,
uh,
did a documentary about him breakfast with hunter maybe or,
no,
but yeah.
One of them,
one of them,
but he's,
he's rolling a joint,
uh,
on the grass somewhere with that Las Vegas visor on and he's,
you know,
talking about how he's really become this caricature and it would be actually be
better if he wasn't alive anymore,
you know,
then it's breaking up with his wife during that.
It was really sad.
There's a scene in that where he hides where he's at like a parking lot.
He doesn't want people to see him and he's standing against the wall and people
are like,
come on,
we've got to go.
He's like,
I just don't want anybody to see me right now.
It was really sad and I,
I tried to take that tragedy too and he wrote great things afterwards.
He was a great friend to people at first.
Like Ron Wyden had this wonderful poet from Louisville was a dear friend of his,
like,
um,
all through his life.
But the tragedy of how much effort he put out to if we want to write about
Trump,
if you want to go after like Tybee did about the financial institution,
the way Thompson did it was to kind of wager time later for time now.
And he talks about that.
He says,
you mean by that chemical speed?
He says doing dexedrine being an alcoholic instead of changing his life and his
rhythms.
He said,
I'm wagering time later for time now I'm using up energy are things that I might
have by burning the candle so brightly at this instant.
Cause I believe I need to go after these moments and I later,
I'm not going to have it.
But I'm making that gamble.
I'm putting the card down right now.
And I think that's terrifying.
And I also think that he gave us brilliant writing over one of the most
remarkable spans in American history because of it.
That's a weird tradition in journalism,
right?
To destroy your body while creating your art.
And,
um,
I think there's a,
according to my friends who are journalists,
there's a big problem with Adderall today and there's a lot of people that are
using it to write and,
um,
it's fucking speed and you know,
you get addicted.
I mean,
Adderall makes everything in front of you closer.
Have you done it?
Yeah.
So my first book was called hyper.
I'm a personal history of Adhd,
so it was not being medicated as a child.
You were medicated as a child,
like having pills forced down my throat,
like all sold six when I took Ritalin for the first time I had,
I had a suicidal moment and like six years old was the first time you were six
you wanted to commit suicide?
I held like a butter knife to my wrist.
I don't remember it.
But yeah,
I kind of remember it,
but yeah.
And it was on Ritalin,
which I've taken now as an adult and I always feel startled when I'm on it.
If I ever take Ritalin now,
why do I like,
well,
I take it to write like this world is incredibly painful,
so I take Adderall now.
Um,
and I,
I take it to how often you take it every day.
I take like 30 milligrams a day really?
And I,
I take it too,
I take it to go into a library and this is what David Wallace wells was talking
about I think like two days ago on the show us.
How
do you read really shitty academic articles where you need the information from
them?
I'm not good at that.
I'm not good at even making like a car reservation,
you know,
like a car rental reservation.
And so this world's going to be painful no matter what.
But there's a functionality that um,
Adderall allows and it's always a wager.
What Thompson writes about is whenever something is given something else's lost,
you never get anything for free in this world.
Thompson understood that better than anybody.
So with him,
with Dexedrine,
I'm not going to say Thompson was hyperactive,
I'm not going to go into that.
But text Adriene like Geiger was like,
Yo,
you're breaking down.
Like you're 26.
You have a wife,
you have a very small child.
You're writing right now.
You want to have your career go forward,
you're not doing well.
And Geiger was like,
I'm a doctor.
I had gone through med school,
you know,
I'd bid it,
I,
I'd been overwhelmed like you Gaga ran every morning,
you know,
he did,
he did other things,
but he,
he took Dex to train.
So I gave it to Thomson.
And for that small period of time it helped.
I mean for me it's like I,
I,
I'm not a good researcher and maybe I would be now,
but the only way I can write about something like hunter s Thompson where I
didn't know him,
I have no experience with him,
is to read everything that he's ever written or been written about him and then
go out and interview people.
And so effort is my only path forward.
And what Adderall helps for me is to take the pain away of that effort,
but it doesn't take it away.
It shifts it around to other aspects and other parts of life.
And I think Thompson when he wrote,
he who makes a piece of himself escapes the pain or gets rid of the pain of
being a man.
We don't listen to that.
Like,
he was like,
this effort is hard.
He's like,
I'm struggling with this effort.
I'm trying to make these beautiful things.
I always think of James Salter fiction writer Aspin um,
um,
resident wrote beautiful novels.
He wrote his whole life till he was 90.
His last novel was at 87.
He wrote a memoir at 76 about being a fighter pilot among other things in the
Korean War lyric.
Literary he did it his whole life.
He didn't,
he didn't burn out for a small period of time.
He's the Antonym to Thompson,
I think when it comes to effort and literary work.
Right.
Um,
do,
do you just take it for work?
Yeah,
I mean you don't have like an issue that you need to take it for my,
I mean we will,
um,
I think that will,
whenever we have something like chemical speed,
whenever we have something like alcohol,
um,
whenever we have something that's not like marijuana or at least marijuana cuts
your mania,
you know,
like whenever we have something else like alcohol or at all,
we need to ask the question as it is taking the pain away and being productive
through those.
Actually hastening your own doom and I think with alcohol is very clear.
It is.
Think with Adderall is more complex.
I think if you do an amount of time release,
you can make it work.
How many Americans do that out of the percent that are prescribed,
you know,
I don't know,
10%,
20%,
like it's dangerous.
How often do you take time off?
I'd say
maybe one or two weeks,
uh,
of,
every three or four months.
And when you do that,
do you feel weird now I just watch movies.
Like I just don't do anything.
It doesn't,
I don't have any productivity.
I don't,
I don't produce.
So the only way you produce is on speed.
The only way I produce the way I want you right now is on speed.
I didn't start taking it till 2010.
Two.
It's crazy that we're talking about this because there's so many people like
you.
It's um,
it's so common how much of the work that we enjoy today,
especially literary work is written by people.
Journalistic work is written by people that are on speed.
That's not new.
I mean that's what Thompson and burrows and southern like this has been.
I believe that our American society,
the situation I'm in,
I have created a situation where I have too much work and it's my fault.
I should not be trying to be a professor and also co report it communist and
also at George Mason in the um,
creative writing program,
you know,
and also then be hosting like people coming out and also then like be trying to
research something that might be my next thing that's too much in the way
Thompson saw dexedrine was that he could make reality match his effort.
So there was no longer the limit.
It was the American dream idea.
If you just put out enough effort,
you'll get it.
And that's why I think he's so brilliantly understood.
The toxicity of the American dream is that the effort is what the story is.
You just because you have a path with the effort to be rich,
to be successful,
that doesn't mean that's a good thing.
That's what we'll actually dismantle you.
Yeah.
It's putting it out.
And I think we forget that.
Do you,
one of the things about hunter that's really intoxicating is that his sort of
self destructive path becomes romantic when you read it and you get involved in
his work and you kind of mimic it,
you know,
it's,
uh,
that's the greatest fallacy I think.
I think what he was trying to say with self destruction was that this was an
incredible threat to our American democracy.
Now,
I don't mean,
I mean,
I mean his,
no romanticism tilling his,
well,
I mean,
the romantic aspect of it was that his work was fantastic.
I mean window was still,
it wasn't,
it was fantastic till it was,
I mean he understood he didn't flood in the failure it was,
but he lived in with,
he spent much more time within the,
the consequences of that bingeing then he did within the success of the bingeing
and that I think he knew that it has letters.
It's really beautiful and heartbreaking.
And in his writing too,
I mean I think that's what's been missed about him is there's no romanticism and
self destruction right towards the end.
He definitely lost his productivity and Yon Warner talked about that and the
Alex give me documentary,
just sticky fingers was a great,
the document,
uh,
the new book on the New Book on Yon Winner has great moments of Thompson in the
70s just being kind of lost.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think,
I think we got to remember that we have an incredible times in American history.
We have times that are going to burn brightly and it's up to each rider to
decide how they'd like to burn next to it.
And if you're going to burn brightly,
they may not have other times.
And that's I think an American thing where you can wager that bright flame,
which means you may have nothing left afterwards.
But Thompson knew that he may have to live in that kind of afterlife at Wa.
One Thompson writes about it so beautifully and the stories I tell myself,
there's some footage of him when he was writing for,
I forget what newspaper somewhat was it somewhere in the Pacific northwest.
What,
what do is you're writing for?
Who is the author of playing off the rail?
Google,
uh,
playing off the rail.
There's a guy who was a journalist,
but year,
do you think it was David Mccumber?
Yes.
David McCumber.
Dave and Macomber employed hunter for a while when David was,
um,
I forget what publication he was working for,
but there's some footage of them community communicating together and you know,
it was trying to get,
Hunter Has San Francisco,
was it San Francisco and hunters out of his fucking mind.
I mean,
it was younger.
You mean he wasn't even that old,
but he was just wracked.
He just couldn't communicate.
He couldn't talk.
And uh,
you know,
he made a beat.
He makes the beast have you escape the pain of articulation.
You escape the pain of saying this is what's wrong.
And American Society for him to say the way he did,
one of his great essays is from 1964 is by going to Hemingway's,
um,
Ketchum Idaho on grave and Hemingway's house.
And it,
it's gorgeous because it talks about Hemingway was a good writer,
one of the best writers when he was writing about an up period.
He understood the 1940 [inaudible] 1930s when there was a firmness to the
reality that he could articulate.
One of the writers goals is to get the pattern to chaos,
is to give an articulation to cast.
But what happens in the 1960s when the chaos has multiplying repeatedly somebody
like Hemingway becomes a literal relic.
Like his narrative no longer fits into the present that he's in.
And Thompson saw Hemingway's decline and he wrote about Hemingway's,
um,
suicide by me,
by his narrative doesn't fit Hemingway's idea of what America was and what a man
should be fit perfectly with what I think the twenties to forties when we
experienced.
But I think in the early 1960s with our social upheaval of civil rights,
of,
um,
you know,
political upheaval,
Hemingway,
it was confusing to him.
It didn't,
it didn't fit anymore.
Like his way of operating no longer articulated the present.
And so Hemingway's last act was to take away his ability to say anything at all.
That was his only,
the last thing he ever said was to say,
I'm not going to say anything anymore.
Was the suicide that Hemingway committed and Thompson wrote about that
gorgeously?
Yeah.
When,
when I was young,
when he wound up killing himself,
owes,
it was almost unsurprising,
you know,
when,
when I read that he had died,
I remember going,
Oh man,
well,
I guess,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it's like you knew that he was deteriorating rapidly.
You knew that he had really bad hips.
He had had hip replacement surgery,
um,
the Ralph stepping leg.
Yeah.
Ralph Steadman had drawn this very crazy image of him with the
artificial hip and yeah,
it looked like pain.
You know what I mean?
But I think that it's not my place to even deal with that because Juan
Thompson's book writes about that moment or one Thompson was in the house and
that's,
that's his and one writes beautifully about the stakes of it,
how painful it was to the people that loved him,
everything about it.
Um,
and how that,
even if that's a logical outcome at that's not,
no,
it needed it.
So it's interesting,
I would say read stories.
I tell myself that moment is so honestly and brilliantly written by Warren.
No,
I'm sure.
Boat Bama.
Oh,
I was getting at is that at the time of his death,
you know,
he was in to sort of a,
he was deteriorating so badly.
He was wearing diapers.
His,
his entire cause of his alcoholism has ability to control.
His bladder was gone.
And so one gave this wonderful speech at George Mason when he came out and he's
like,
how do you write honestly about your father?
And he asked the question of like,
should I include this detail?
And he was like,
if my father was alive,
I couldn't include that.
But that's why I chose in a sense to write my book where my father was dead
because I think my father would want me to write honestly,
but also not want me to include that if he was still alive.
And so he included that detail and he talked about that,
how the struggle to include that detail,
which I think brilliantly articulate what you're saying,
which is the deterioration in the sadness of it.
And I mean we have finite amounts of energy or effort.
We really do.
We have to take care of ourselves.
And if we don't,
we will pay that price at some point.
We're going to pay it anyways.
We're all headed to the same place whether we want to or not,
you know?
And so I think hunter's a really terrifying and beautiful example of one wager
of chips that were made for the 1960 [inaudible] and 1970s.
And I think the best way to honor that is to,
you know,
apply the brilliance that he forged in carved to the situation we have right now
with corruption,
Donald Trump,
um,
uh,
of an attack on American democracy where American democracy is basically,
it's like what early says democracy is a train and we arrive at the station
would get off,
like they'd be basically used the ladder to get to the attic and now Trump's
pulling up the ladder.
And I think Thompson would understand that really,
really well.
And I think reading him now,
whether you know him or not,
helps you,
and that's why I wrote free kingdom was so that it can be a lens on his,
his work going back or just on this president right now.
No,
they'll
be regardless of Trump.
I think what he really represents is a brilliant historical time capsule.
And He,
he sort of captures that time period,
that upheaval pre-internet where the world was in chaos.
Like no one else.
He,
he,
he encapsulated this very strange moment in history,
which I don't think is nearly as strange as the moment we're going through right
now.
I think this is probably the most trained moment ever.
Yeah.
But he,
he nailed it and he nailed it in a very,
very unique way that still today I mean to oil.
That was another thing I want to ask you about.
Well why did him and Tom Wolfe,
like Tom Wolfe got some of his tapes from some of the,
was it the Honda,
the hell's angels,
Palisade,
just parties and um,
some crazy orgy that was going on.
And he gave him the tapes to this,
like what was all that about?
So when Thomson was covering the hell's angels,
um,
they believed the Carter culture at the left in the 1960,
65,
66.
We're talking about Kenkey Z,
we're talking about the antiwar movement,
the free speech movement with Mario Savio.
They believe the hell's angels were on their side.
They were fellow countercultural lists that are also outside of the ballgame.
And so key,
the and Thompson were having a drink after being on the cake.
Qed,
or like some local TV show in San Francisco.
And [inaudible] background is,
he was a wrestler at Oregon.
He grew up on a dairy farm.
He'd come down to Stanford to write for what is now the Stegner fellowship.
But back then was the graduate program at Stanford.
He had moved up to La Honda on the success of his first book.
One flew over the cuckoo's nest and had just written another beautiful book.
Um,
and so Thompson was like,
yeah,
I'm ready about the hell's angels.
And he was like,
Yo,
I or I'd like to meet them.
Tom's was like,
okay.
And so Thompson knew how dangerous the hell's angels were at war,
or I think people either romanticize them or exaggerated there danger,
but he's like,
okay,
I'll set them up.
And He,
you know,
he contacted the chapter with Keasy.
So on August 7th,
I think of 1965,
like the hell's angels came to La Honda.
Alan Ginsburg was there with Keasy.
Um,
Alpert was there.
You know who that like all of the,
all the Stanford intellectuals were there and they made a huge banner that says
the Merry Pranksters,
welcome the hell's angels.
And Thompson rolled up with the,
this isn't,
this isn't the given you documentary Thompson rolled up with his family.
Um,
one was a child,
a baby in the backseat San.
He was in the front seat and he pulled up.
And what Thompson saw was Ken Keyes,
he giving acid in red cups,
like Red k cups to the hell's angels.
Thompson was like,
well,
we're getting the fuck out of here.
And so he grabs his wife and his son,
they go to San Clemente,
which is on the other side.
They have like a big picnic.
And on the way back they're like,
well,
let's just check it out.
Let's see what it's like.
And they kind of pull it and he's driving this old like roadster.
They pull in and everybody's watching on a giant trampoline screen,
like the five hour stream of consciousness footage from the merry pranksters
trip across the,
um,
across the u s which is what Tom offered about and comes,
it's like,
all right,
they're not eating each other skulls like we can hang out a little bit.
So they hung out and it was interesting how acid pacified the angels instead of
made them violent.
And that's what acid,
you know,
of course that's what acid is,
but they spent the night hanging out there.
Thompson was writing.
So He's like,
I'm not going to do drugs.
He's like,
I'll have a few drinks.
He's taking notes for his,
his book and later on in the night,
him and Alan Ginsburg,
and this is something I cut out of the book,
are like,
let's go get some beer.
And so the cops are sticking out the property and Ginsburg and Thompson and get
pulled over by the cops.
Thompson stubborn.
He's talking to the cops.
He gets a ticket because his red lens for his taillight is cracked.
And he's like,
come on dude,
that's turn a box.
Like,
I can't,
I'm a journalist.
The cops are like,
why are you writing about them?
And they're talking about like people being taken away to jail and kids were,
goes wasn't what's in what's in Redwood City,
man.
Tableau,
he goes,
it's called a jail Allen.
And that goes back to talking to the cops and all of this.
And Thompson was friends with Ginsberg and so they go back into the party.
Thompson realizes that Neal Cassidy,
who's blackout drunk,
who is Dean Moriarty and on the road by Jack Kerouac,
that's the character on who it was based.
His two or three girlfriends,
one of them is having an orgy with the hell's angels at this cabin off to the
side and Thompson sees it and he describes it in two ways when he writes about
it,
but he did audio nuts.
So he did audio notes of step by step and he describes to us like just horrific
where she's barely awake.
I'm like,
she's,
she's catatonic.
And they bring in Neal Cassady to hook up with her too.
It's horrific.
And He articulates this horror.
I had a friend who is a good feminist writer lakes who's dear to me.
She's like,
didn't have any,
you wrote about a fucking white guy,
like whatever.
She's like,
he did most of it.
Right.
She's like,
you excused Thompson in that moment.
You should have just let it stand and write about it in the book instead of try
to talk about how upset he was saying it.
Thomson was really upset.
So why did she say that?
It doesn't make any sense because I think she thought that I was making the
experience less authentic by trying to qualify it for our current times.
But why would that be the case when you were just expressing?
Explain?
No,
I should've just little Thompson.
I think I should have let him stand more instead of showing or amplifying his
emotion too much.
But you're saying this based on her criticism or all personal opinion?
No,
I think that he was really upset,
but I think him being really upset is secondary to whatever she was
experiencing.
Right,
but you're writing about him?
Yes.
So I stand by it like I thought about that.
What I wrote it.
I stand by it,
but what was,
what does her criticism again that by amplifying his upsetness,
by like showing how upset he was,
that that's too much of an excuse for him.
Just just write it where he was.
She didn't think he should have done stepped in and said,
no,
nothing like that.
She was on point.
She thought I shouldn't.
She felt the effort on my part to try to explain his upsetness instead of just
having him be upset with one sentence and then go on.
She thought it was overriding.
I thought it was a fair criticism where I overwrote it,
but long story short,
Thompson goes back and he goes to Keasy and he goes,
this is one of the worst things I've ever seen and this is in the documentary,
but he says the case then why would,
why would it be that you were overriding it?
That doesn't seem like you overrode it.
I always worry.
I'm over writing it.
One of my great,
it's one of my great fears is that if someone sees something like that,
I think it's important that you accurately relay the emotions that they
experience when they're watching a horrific event.
I mean,
he did describe it as horrific,
but how much of it is my cultural perception of this moment that I'm giving too
much to Thomson and how much of it was what he act accurately experience,
but he's talked about.
So I think just giving his words instead of saying a little bit,
you know,
going okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so when he goes back and he on his notes that night,
these are the notes he gave to Ken Casey.
I'm sorry,
these are the notes.
Tom.
Tom Wolfe.
He says it just gave him the recordings.
No,
I don't think there were actual recordings.
I don't.
I think that is what Tom Wolfe said.
No,
that's what one of the documentaries said.
Tom Wolfe said he gave me the record,
the notes of it.
So maybe be the notes of what happened.
And Tom Wolfe,
I know what those notes are.
Use those notes to recreate that scene in electric koolaid acid test.
Um,
and so this is why we talk about truth later in life.
Thompson,
some biographies might've said that he actually recorded the event.
He didn't,
he went back and he took these long audio notes of like shadow and light and the
whore that he saw it.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
He took the audio notes,
the recordings.
He made the recording.
Yes,
yes.
And then he gave us a tumble often.
Tom Wolfe.
Exactly.
But some people have said that he put the tape recorder in the room.
That's not what I meant.
I meant he gave him the recordings and they're beautiful.
They're terrifying.
But it's about like violence and shadow and light and horror.
You know,
it's a horrific,
it's a horrific scene that says Thompson's brilliance at that age.
He could in an audio note,
get the fucking images and details that he needs to express the,
that,
the nature of that incident.
And so Tom Wolfe use those to create it himself.
But 10 Thompson recreated it to art,
wrote about it in Hell's angels,
but in a more distant way than wolfed it,
which is crazy cause he was actually there.
It's fucking crazy,
dude.
That was the first time Thompson never took acid because he was so upset.
He went to Keasy and he's like,
fuck it,
I'm not a journalist anymore.
That's so horrific.
What I saw.
Fuck it.
I had friends that had told him that he's a personality where if he did acid to
go to the bottom of the well for him,
you know,
this would be a really horrific thing.
And so he's like,
I don't care anymore.
And instead he just walked around and like,
was that piece like,
it's always funny when someone tells you how you're going to recycle a drug.
Relax,
right?
Cause you forget you're going to react to it.
How you're gonna react to it.
What was it like for you when you finally finish this?
When you,
when you put the last page down and you knew you were done.
Um,
I know that you like me,
uh,
share.
Uh,
we have an adoration for this guy.
That's,
uh,
you mean he's one of my,
for sure.
Personal heroes.
I mean the last image I wrote was,
um,
one of the most people think Thompson's Thompson writes his something he didn't
actually see was with Nixon's helicopter.
He saw it on,
on TV,
left the White House lawn.
What happens is that,
you know,
giant helicopter with the white top and the blue,
it's wheels lose their pressure so the wheels are flattened at the bottom.
But as the rotors begin to bring it up,
they become a long good wheels that's still touch the ground.
Thompson wrote that image and I've always loved that image.
Um,
so I was writing that in a sense when I was at Seapak it,
I'm 2018 last year and I was walking out just after I wrote that.
And pence,
this helicopter was on the lawn right there.
It was lifting off and I saw the wheels along it just like that.
And I just had so much respect for Thompson's ability as we talk about fiction
as a narrative writer detail that instant,
you know,
and to detail the way that that along gated and went to have that be the emotion
of Nixon finally departing.
And so I felt,
you know,
I felt I gave it,
I throw as hard as I could if there are as many pictures as I could,
I threw for as long as I can,
you know,
and I hope that everybody knows it's my version of Thompson and then it's a
version of Thompson written through the Lens of Donald Trump.
But hopefully that it's through the effort and through the detail of version
that might bring more people to Thompson while also at the same time for Thomson
fans,
um,
you know,
being something that they can respect and engage.
Beautiful.
Well thank you for writing it.
Thank you for,
I'm just highlighting who this guy was and uh,
thanks for all your work,
man.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for being a good fan and for highlighting his work to you that you're
beautiful poster.
We didn't even talk about it.
The Aspen Wall poster that you have right in here is just so gorgeous.
I got a hundred shit all over the place.
It's fantastic.
It's good.
Yeah.
No,
I'm a,
I'm a die hard for sure.
It wasn't man.
Thank you brother.
I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
Tell everybody the book,
where to get it,
how to get it free kingdom a hundred Thompson's 10 year.
I'm manic crusade against American fascism.
It's available everywhere on Amazon.
I'm at Tim to navy on Twitter and you should check out the guns voice,
um,
Twitter Hashtag,
which has Thompson's quotes all the time,
which is great.
And you know,
it was a great guy on Instagram too.
There's a couple of them at Jack's Gonzo Gonzo and the jackalope.
He's another guy who's got a bunch of grinning.
Nita Thompson does a great job on Facebook and if you are interested in
Thompson,
you don't know him.
I hope you read Free Kingdom and not to lens on his work,
you know,
to organize it.
And if you love Thompson,
I hope you read freaking them too,
because that's a way to engage them again.
Beautiful.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you,
Joe.
Okay.